covered vaccines are being rolled out
around the world
but a determined minority are choosing
to refuse them
in america around 30 of adults are yet
to take the jab but what if the choice
was taken out of their hands
governments and companies are currently
debating whether covert 19 vaccines
should become mandatory
as the debate becomes increasingly
polarized dividing families colleagues
and communities our correspondents
answer your questions on this topic
what is the argument for forcing people
to get vaccinated
i mean the argument for mandatory
vaccination is that you get better
coverage and that's good for public
health it's good for everyone's safety
and obviously protects people who can't
get vaccinated or who aren't protected
well by vaccines and what i would say is
that i think a certain amount of arm
twisting by governments is perfectly
justified
but when it goes too far
and um it becomes too coercive then what
worries me is that in infringes on
people's you know bodily autonomy and
right to decide what goes on with their
body
and it also
shows that you've kind of basically lost
the argument the public health argument
that these things are a good thing for
you to take
why is the debate becoming so polarized
this is a hugely divisive issue and yes
we're seeing it in workplaces we're
seeing it in families where um people
are arguing and trying to convince
family members to get vaccinated and
others are trying to convince them to
not get vaccinated we're seeing people
who are vaccinated claiming that
their rights are being infringed upon
right i can't go to yoga and know that
when i'm in the hot yoga room i'm not
breathing in coven i don't know if um i
go to the supermarket whether or not i
am safe and then other people are saying
well absolutely not this is an
infringement on our rights um you can't
force me to do anything that and put
anything unnatural into my body et
cetera et cetera so we are definitely
seeing in the u.s uh a big split it's
another example of extreme polarization
in the us and you know the us is facing
quite an uncertain future it's facing
uh lots and
more covert outbreaks in uh
states that um are struggling to deal
with these cases
um you know winter's not going to be
far off
and so i can see
why there's a lot of frustration
and anger and uh kind of push from the
vaccinated um to have the unvaccinated
you know roll up their arms
are covered vaccines mandatory anywhere
code vaccines by and large are not
mandatory although it will depend where
you are in the world and uh what job you
do as well um and also it's changing uh
as we speak people are formulating um
new policies on this all the time
um italy was the first european country
to mandate uh coveted vaccines for
healthcare workers and i think as we
look forward we'll see lots of
healthcare workers being pressured by
governments to get vaccines
and in the us we were seeing this really
interesting pushback against vaccine
mandates before they were even
implemented many states had passed laws
against
mandatory vaccinations states like
florida but with the the latest wave of
covid uh cases we're seeing that
many other many state governments many
city governments as well as private
institutions are starting to mandate
those vaccines we're seeing that the
federal government is mandating
vaccination or regular testing among
federal employees we're seeing states
like california and virginia require it
of their employees
new york city is also requiring it of
its city employees
private companies like walmart are also
requiring vaccination
have vaccines ever been made mandatory
in the past
the first vaccine that was ever made
mandatory was the smallpox vaccine and
that happened in britain and that was in
1853
and
children were required to be vaccinated
and there was a fine imposed which would
be equivalent to about 180 today
and what was really interesting about
this is it stimulated the rise of the
anti-vaccination movement a really
strong
uprising a really strong movement that
actually spread overseas and the
arguments are all very similar to what
we hear today a lot of the hysterical
misinformation so we do have to be
careful when we make vaccines um
mandatory that we don't kind of
stimulate this you know huge outcry at
what is seen as to be
an unfair uh situation
do incentive programs to encourage
vaccinations work
so we've seen a lot of really
interesting incentive programs in the us
some states like ohio were
have had a lottery for
one million dollar
uh checks to people who got vaccinated
we also saw a hundred dollar gift card
incentives in new york city and of
course we saw
retailers giving away free donuts and
other things as well
um
unfortunately a recent study found
that looks particularly at ohio they
found that the lotteries were not
actually
incentivizing people to get the vaccine
so it looks like they might not be
working but mayor bill de blasio of new
york city thinks that his 100 incentive
system did increase vaccinations in
early august so my favorite uh was in a
philippine town the mayor is planning a
cow raffle
um but we've seen all sorts of things
being offered from uber lifts
you know in lebanon um to discounted
takeaway meals so really it depends on
the country you're in as to what the
government is prepared to offer you
but you know as tamara said um
you know there's a limited extent to
which these are going to work they will
work for a few people
but they won't work for everyone
[Music]
can employers make vaccines mandatory
you know what's possible will really
depend on what country you're in some
countries like canada it's certainly
quite hard uh in britain if you are
hiring new staff then certainly that
does appear to be the case um i know
that employers here do want to do this
um for existing staff um and i think
what we will see in britain and in other
countries is that this will get tested
legally
as employers bring this in and in the
united states state governments and
private employers can definitely mandate
vaccines there are three exceptions that
tend to come into play there's um
personal beliefs religion as well as
medical exceptions and in some states
like california new york they don't even
actually allow for a religious exemption
or a personal belief exemption so
it's actually quite surprising when you
dig in
do you think governments will ever make
covert vaccines mandatory well we know
that they have in saudi arabia we know
that the moscow government
has rolled out a mandatory vaccination
program for
service sector workers so i think it's
clear that some governments will do this
but in other places citizens just won't
accept it and it won't happen
it is not
constitutional for the federal
government to require all u.s citizens
to get a vaccine what would be more
likely to happen is that state
governments require it in
their to varying degrees and as we can
see currently that will depend that
would depend widely on the politics of
the state we're seeing that while some
states like california are requiring
vaccination among public employees other
states
are banning like florida are banning
mass in schools or anywhere are
are banning vaccine passports so
based on the politics and of course the
legal constraints we're not likely to
see a vaccine mandate in the entire
united states
i'm natasha loder the health policy
editor of the economist
you can read more of our coverage on
kobit 19 by clicking on the link
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]